cuz he's like okay you know we got
exactly what the people want we got one
more game and I think it's still
possible that it could be a draw and we
get another game but highly unlikely
very good chance that this is the final
game of the match and a must- win for
Hikaru Nakamura and he unbalances the
game immediately he plays E4 E5 but he
puts his Knight on E7 he tries to get
opposite side castling but he's already
in trouble because you can't Castle
short you're going to drop the H6 Pawn
so I don't like what he's gotten here
early on the Knight can land on D5 this
is a Carlson type of position it is but
you know what you got to cut uh he car
some slack here because he needs an
imbalanced position and sometimes you
have to just take a bad position
straight up and then turn it into a good
one later so at the very least it's not
some sort of equal game that's going to
be a draw and I like what he's doing
he's gotten his King to relative safety
he could strike with F5 and create
tension in the center that's a very
thematic idea in these types of
positions Aman instead he's playing this
more def Ely though with Rook C8 Knight
D4 I think Magnus is also uh he's
looking like he wants to go for some
trades here Bishop A2 and queen E6 is
going to pick up the pawn what a shot no
way and now hikaro with a clearly better
position up a full pawn and wh's King
has been
breached yeah and now with the with the
time getting as low on the match clock
this is it guys this game needs to be a
win for hikaro and he set himself up to
do it but he's got the hardest task
still ahead of on because if he goes for
the queen trade try winning that
opposite colored Bishop end game against
Magnus Carlson hikaro says out of the
question I'm keeping the Kings on the
board but Magnus keeps improving his
position
whoa he wants one eventually y Oh I
thought he should have played F5
there that would have been very
interesting but instead he's just
looking to simplify okay A5 Rook A1 B6
the pawns are going to go in dark
squares King is going to go to B7 what a
move by Hikaru shutting down White's
rook and Magnus has to to bring
everything back I think the position is
now getting worse yep he car is playing
really well because he's the Rooks were
too uh Advanced on the king side like
what are they doing Magnus bring them
back and King B7 another amazing move
Nakamura says hey you want to attack
down the a file no no no no no I'm the
boss down the a file Magnus doing
everything he can to distract Nakamura
here comes the queen here come the M
threats Dire Straits for Magnus he's on
the ropes I don't even I don't even know
what to recommend here Queen C1 Rook A2
it's insane I can't find a move hearu is
doing it he's got 15 seconds to find a
move and Magnus closes his eyes and goes
all
in2 Rook A2 he missed it oh my goodness
Rook takes B6 again Rook takes B6 and
it's over Rook takes B6 over and he miss
oh my goodness he still has something
maybe Rook C7 for draw both Rooks are
sacrificed oh my this might be winning
by the way but he only needs a draw as
the match clock expires and he car is
exasperated oh my gosh I'm
hikaro had forced mate and it's a draw
by agreement and it's the match he
offers a draw a gentleman's draw and I
mean what a finish it literally comes
down to the last game and look at the
smile on even hikaru's face these guys
are just two Titans two Champions going
out one another you cannot script this
any better